and right off the bat this series took a
turn
i mean you're into the opening seconds
of the game
when james harden goes to the hole and
comes down gripping that right hamstring
injury that had put him on the shelf for
21 games late in the year and
he did not return
so we and the last word we got was he
was headed
for an mri and so has left the building
headed for an mri
uh so we will see what that this it's
going to be the exact
same situation with the lakers
lakers yeah with lebron and a.d ernie
you
can't not just show up for the playoffs
you have to play basketball to get in
shape you can go a stretch
if you had leg injuries but but the
playoffs are so grueling because you're
playing every other day
like you're gonna excuse me and the
intensity
and the intensity there's nothing you
can do when you're sitting on the
sidelines
because you because that's the thing
about it if you hurt your leg you can't
do any conditioning
played two games late in the season
played all five and that first round
win over the celtics but out in the
opening seconds of this one